Speaker 1: All right. We have a voicemail number
and that number is two one nine two, David.
Here's a great voicemail because it points out the
impossibility. It points out the conflict between
different Biden conspiracy theories. On the one
hand, the idea that Biden is just a puppet and
someone else is really running the show. And on
the other hand, the idea that Biden is ruining
everything and is responsible for everything
bad that's going on. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I'm curious about
something I thought maybe you could answer
for me. Yeah. Why is it that Biden. Is a puppet.
Kamala Harris is running the country Kamala.
He's an old man who just babbles and doesn't
even know what room is and. Yet it's completely
his fault every time something goes wrong.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, this is great, because
if someone else is actually the Biden
puppet master, we we should be blaming
them whenever something goes wrong. Right. But
Biden is simultaneously a disastrous president,
making disastrous decisions who deserves singular
blame for everything that goes bad and also
not actually in charge of anything. And other
people are controlling it. It's just yet another
one. You know, it's sort of like this is the
greatest vaccine ever developed by Trump,
which we actually aren't going to go and accept
because the virus isn't that serious and we don't
really need vaccines. Well, then in what sense is
it really a major accomplishment for Trump if it's
a vaccine we don't need for something that's not
serious anyway, these people are pathetic. On the
bonus show today, we will talk about Joe Mansion's
latest list of demands and whether anybody should
listen to them. We will talk about a three million
dollar deal that's been reached in the case of the
rough arrest of a woman with dementia. And lastly,
Amazon is going to open some cashier lists,
Whole Foods stores next year. There's also
Amazon go stores. And this could be a real
paradigm shift in terms of the way grocery stores
are organized. And I have some specific thoughts
I'll share with you all of that on today's
bonus show. Get instant access by signing up at
Unidentified: Going Patman dot
com. And I will see you then.